for the cardinals they welcome back
miles michaelis his season debut
and his first
appearance
since game one of the 2019 nlcs two outs
men at the corners here's javier bios
and he gets one into left field to put
the cubs on top
baez knocks in his 30th of the season
peterson who was hit by the pitch to
start the inning scores and it's one
nothing chicago
here in the first inning think about
alzheimer's pitching here in st louis
what comes to mind well first of all you
know working ahead in the count
and once he gets command of the fastball
then really trying to use that slider it
really gets good downward tilt and i
think that's the pitch today that can
induce some ground balls
here's a smash that's fair backhanded by
rizzo good play gets up feeds elsa like
coming to the bag nice play by rizzo
backhanding the ball over near the first
baseline that was not a routine play
and the number eight hitter
whose numbers don't look like a number
eight hitter nico horner hitting 349.
will stand in
that is back to michaelis and
wow
made that look easy
ho-hum
well typically you don't want your
starting pitcher trying to catch a ball
with your pitching hand but
he basically just squashed it
[Applause]
and said yeah
[Applause]
i guess it's okay if you feel it cleanly
yeah not on the fingertips but that's
what you're worried about elaine thomas
waits for a 2-2 pitch and strikes out
looking who was he's pitching he really
is who was who was the uh who was the
best on that high school staff at
harvard west lake um
i i mean i had the best
numbers at the end of it but but max and
lucas had much better stuff that's why
they went you know seventh and lucas
even when he had was blown out still
winning i think he went 16th or
something their stuff was unbelievable
still is
batter is miles michaelis you go ahead
and say it
you can say you were the best yeah i
mean numbers-wise yeah that's the way
that's the way it turned out but those
guys were uh are and we're in still
filthy
he's swinging a miss strike three and
alzheimer's rolling along
here's horner
runners will go 3-2 pitch is flipped
into right that ball is fouled and
caught by gold schmidt down the line
two in the inning
one down fourth inning
cubs lead one nothing ten in a row set
down by alzalei just
and that's down into the corner
cardinals have their first hit
and it's an extra base hit
dug out by bryant goldschmidt has a
one-out double
the difference there would have went
away with a slider he tried to sneak a
fastball by him after throwing a
fastball up and in
you really didn't want anything close to
the plate and i really thought he was
going to go to the slider away it would
have gotten goldsmith swinging you see
him keep his head down and go the other
way for the first hit
and finally they're going to get a
chance to see this guy pitch out of the
stretch
hey i'm wearing a wire no no funny talk
today all right i don't want to
incriminate my boys
trying to tell myself to swing earlier
in the count
my first pitch i just
i'm not there yet i've been doing it but
hey i was i looked fast
i thought for a second maybe i had a
knock through that hole
[Applause]
well just when the cardinals got miles
michael is back they may lose him
he was warming up and
he was just barely tossing the ball and
as the inning was just about ready to
start
he called the
training staff out to
check on him and they're going to take
him out
and he's
after every throw he was looking over
to the dugout
obviously won't guess he's
been bothered the last couple of years
with
injuries
and obviously could be anywhere on his
body but he's not going to be able to
continue
monster leon recently returned from the
injured list
one-on-one with a 7.94 era
this will be his seventh appearance he
has started two games
now it's so-so maybe he can get
something started with two outs
garcia here's a line drive into right
that is slicing and down into the corner
by edmundo sosa
he's going to go for three
throw by horner is
too late
and a triple with two out here in the
fifth by sosa you never want to make
that third out at third you got to be in
there safely without a
close play but he hit it down the right
field line as you mentioned and then
turned on the burners
the cubs are all looking into the dugout
to see if
the bench wants to challenge this
here it is tremendous relay and throw
and i think
he got in there was
before the tag if the tag would win
straight
[Applause]
they're not going to look at it so it is
a triple with two down here's lane
thomas
here's one in the center ty game
wayne thomas delivers
with two down it's 1-1
that is on a line to center and it's a
diving catch by vader
what a play by harrison bater in center
the defense for the cardinals vastly
improved since last year and where it's
noticeable
is they're outfielders they have speed
they can go cut off
extra base hits make plays like this
talking to adam wainwright he said that
this was the biggest difference he
noticed in the club this year the speed
in the outfield of course the corner
defense yadier molina is going to lead
off in the seventh inning o2 pitch is
hit down the line
it is
gone
cardinals on top
two to one
and the many faces of yadier molina will
have a smile on it home run number seven
on the year
and he puts his team out in front for
the first time tonight he sat on a
slider and didn't come off it had some
good swings and he got another one and
one of the rare sliders that backed up
again and he
everybody knew it there was three people
that knew it he watched the head of the
catcher the pitcher knows it molina's
head goes down let's go to the bat
and run on the board and molina and the
cardinals hoping that holds up here's
alex reyes 13 for 13 and save chances
2-0 pitch
fly ball into left
williams near the line cardinals win it
2-1